[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 41 of
GameSpot after dark
I'm your host Jake Decker and joining me
this week is Lucy James hello Kelly
plaguey hi and John Luke psyche hello
how's everyone doing we were just
talking about this why you went to get
some water with tired really tired
mm-hm I'm tired too I'm going to do my
best to I don't know inject energy into
myself yeah I think it's oh so I was
talking to people and like doing stuff I
just find that I'm sleeping a lot more
and I'm just like feeling I'm getting
that mid-afternoon slump at 4:20 in the
afternoon yeah I mean it's like saying
9:30 and I'm like time to go to bed hmm
I am tired I mean I'm always like this
I'm tired literally all day until like 9
p.m. and then I'm like alright it's time
to be alive time to finish up my flower
guide manual crossings oh yeah so
Michael does I see him putting things in
like for like published feedback and
like 10 o'clock and I'm like alright man
I have the same like circadian rhythm
and that we're both completely nocturnal
people yeah he always jokes that he
doesn't start working in till like 4:00
p.m. cuz I used to be really nocturnal
person but then I would counterbalance
it by sleeping in really late but
unfortunately these days the absolute
latest I can be asleep by is 9:30 asleep
until is 9:30 so now I'm still awake at
night but also I don't get the lion yep
it just sucks when I was in college I
literally would go to bed at like 6:00
a.m. and then wake up at 4 p.m. so bad
it was so depressing but that's just
like how my body is so I've just
permanently tired and it's the life that
I accept hey I wrote a book all about
sleep and there people who are just
biologically wired that way you can't
really change it and that's one of the
it's one of the things that they're
trying to figure out with schools and
kids is because obviously kids need to
wake up early to go to school because
parents have to go to work but that's
actually really bad for kids because
especially teenagers because there are
some people who just can't go to sleep
at like 9:30 10:00 and they want to wake
up they want to go to bed it like I
don't know two three a.m. and they want
to wake up at like 11 or so yeah when I
was in high school I probably got I want
to say like six hours of school week
yeah and that's really bad yeah kids got
mine you just got a roll out of bed and
hit go on the zoom call stay in your
pajamas I totally don't do that oh I
totally don't stay in bed until 944
scene well anyway why don't we talk
about what we've been playing this week
Callie do you want to kick it off with
some with your animal crossing corner
sure um you know I'm just still playing
the animal crossing because I finally
gotten into the swing of like decorating
my island a little bit more because I
was so focused on collecting information
for guides that like I really neglected
the the decoration part so I've been
enjoying that and like Jake said I did
complete the flower guide John Lewis
helping out with some some graphics for
that as well and basically what I did
was I looked at the date of mind
information and I sourced it obviously
but I took that information and it's all
very technical if you've read the like
raw data mind guides and I I tried to
make it a little bit more streamlined
for people who aren't interested in like
like flowers have genes and stuff and
like you can totally I for the turnip
guide I actually read read literal code
like hey I read code deciphered it and
then translated that into like English
for the guide and for Florida is the the
guides were actually they were it wasn't
just Rock
there was a technical explanation
there's binary involved and like so I
stripped all of that out of
GameSpot's guide and tried to make it a
little more accessible
I still talk about the jeans though in
the guide so shout out to all those data
miners I used I don't have a profit pal
a pl eh I did an advanced flower
genetics guide and I linked out to that
in ours if you're curious about the
actual technical specifics that's what I
do
when does Museum day our museum week
start that's soon isn't it the 17th or
18th I forget so one thing I'm really
curious about so museum days gonna be
fun I'm gonna have fun with that I'm so
curious about wedding season oh yeah for
two reasons yeah one so I have seen I
have seen all of the items online that
are coming in the the wedding update so
I kind of have an idea but the the thing
I don't understand is in sub if your if
your island is in the southern
hemisphere is it also wedding season for
you cuz it's a full-on winter bite by
June and like the southern hemisphere so
you can have a nice winter wedding did
they just have the different wedding
season or is it like well cuz did they
get like cherry blossoms at the same
time we did no it's different right yeah
but this is the first time it'll have
been like a a post release update that
may or may not be seasonal so I'm
curious to see how that works if you are
in the southern hemisphere or you have
southern hemisphere atmosphere
hemisphere I love me I saw the name
asphere that wasn't Australian I tried
my best
no I didn't um anyway if you have one of
those and you know if it's gonna be
wedding season or not maybe your
Nintendo Direct is different or
something and you've got a different
update from them I'd be curious to find
that out because I've been having a hard
time finding answers mm-hmm I was gonna
say you can't time skip Pena cuz it's
one of those ones that patch in yeah
yeah so cherry blossoms wasn't like that
you could
from the very like from the time we got
it before release you could time skip
into April or October if you were in the
southern hemisphere and get cherry
blossoms yeah so yeah you know exciting
stuff for me I read home a week than I
have I drew some punnett squares in my
notebook I drink I genuinely find that
stuff fascinating though like me and my
girlfriend have been like getting into
the the flower game I guess and like we
just learned about how if you send if
somebody else waters your flower is like
it like the chances of them growing so
we like tried it one night and then like
has like three times the amount of like
flowers and hybrids grow so we're like
oh my god we have to do this every night
now so like I'm I'm all in on the flower
so you're guys again excellent thank you
the visitor watering bonus is sick
basically you can get if you have five
people water your flowers like not
including yourself if you have five
friends come and water your flowers you
have an almost 100 percent chance of
that flower producing another flower the
next day so you could basically be like
okay here's my patch of flowers invite
five friends over have them water it
give them a prize or whatever I don't
know how your dynamic with your friends
is but we literally did this thing cuz
John Luke's girlfriend and I plan a
little cross them together sometimes and
we had this group and we literally just
went to each girl's island Oh
respectively and watered her flowers you
Lucy you should come to the girls flower
water and yeah so you get like a super
good bonus and then the other thing that
people may or may not know about it with
flowers last thing I'll say about
flowers because this is all I've been
thinking about for the past like two or
three days is um you can clone a flower
so you can breed two flowers right
you're probably familiar with how that
works
but flowers can also produce another
flower by themselves if they're watered
and the chance of that happening with
what the visitor watering bonus goes up
and the thing about that is like why
that's important if you're just you know
casual you like the color of a certain
flower that's a really efficient way to
like duplicate a hybrid so if you only
have like one purple rose you can try to
clone it instead of having to get two
more white roses and breed them but if
you're thinking about the genetics of
flowers like the code that makes the
flower whatever color it is there's
multiple combinations that result in the
same color and then those combinations
like ten results in a third new color
and that's why getting blue roses is
super hard so cloning a flower if you
know it's like the right genes you can
clone it and it'll have the exact same
genes so that makes it way more
efficient to breed those really
difficult flowers and I laid that out in
the flower guide like how that works and
I named them different things so you can
keep track hopefully but John Luke's
gonna make cool art so context right now
geez I feel like you need a degree in
like biology genes and stuff it's
Mendelian genetics basic Mendelian
genetics she would have study probably
your freshman year like the kind of
squares so you have like recessive genes
and stuff so you know like dominant and
recessive genes like when you're talking
about P plans like Gregor Mendel text of
the pea plants there's like capital R
lowercase R it don't come at me yeah so
that's in Animal Crossing except it's
it's coded just in binary so the the guy
that I looked at did translate it from
the binary code into like punnett square
style letters and then I then made an
abstraction of that in my guide so you
don't have to worry about all the
letters and stuff and all the science as
much I kind of get into it there's a I
started college in science in exam
coming
if I was a ninth grade biology teacher I
would use Animal Crossing it's like the
way to teach the kids about this like
that's that's the way to do it yeah
every bring your switches into class
like the normal plane switch in class
you know they're you know they're doing
they're taking photos of themselves and
then making that they're zoom background
and then they're hiding so it looks like
they're paying attention and they're
frozen and then they play switch oh my
god like why we did a board game kind of
day we used tabletop sim at the weekend
and we're playing with Daniel Cooper
from rkg and his zoom background is a
loop of him reaching in and looking like
he's giving him a cup of tea and then
the Cooper like the actual Cooper like
picked up a drink and like I didn't I
was like looking away something else and
I looked back
a gin and he got the fright of my life
because I know that he lives why I was
like Dan crowd Hughes third kick game
spot had that like tweet that got like
500,000 likes of him just walking in on
zoom and then I feel like after that
everyone just started doing all these
like zoom zoom videos of people just
walking in on themselves it's good stuff
but anyway jean-luc what have you been
playing I'm playing a lot of things but
I've been playing rock band III few
weeks ago I mentioned how we were
playing guitar hero cuz my girlfriend
got guitar hero because she loves guitar
hero and that made me really want to
play rock band cuz that's what I ended
up like really getting into so we it was
a bit of an ordeal
I always is with that game it always is
so I don't have any of my old rock band
stuff anymore and the only one you can
play on modern systems is for I don't
care for the song list and for like I
was like that's not what I want I want
rock band want a lot rock band too like
that's what I want so I had my parents
ship my xbox 360 across the country here
and
and we bought on eBay like it was like
250 dollars and it came with like drum
kit guitar microphone and then rock band
one two and then they threw in a copy of
a Jeff damn Def Jam Rapstar for good
measure which was great
and yeah we've been playing and it's
been a lot of fun it's unfortunately
also been kind of a technical mess the
kick pedal likes to disconnect which
makes the drums unplayable at times it's
weird because it's like sometimes it's
fine
like I'm not a hundred percent sure what
causes it so like sometimes we'll be
like okay I'll only slightly press down
on it and that'll work and then
eventually it'll just disconnect and I
have to like unplug it if I replug it in
that it works for like another minute or
so and then so you can only play minute
long songs on drums
yeah and we're at the hard songs now
we're at like green grass and high tides
which is like nine minutes long and
that's what I was like we have I can't I
can't do this we can't so we've actually
put on hiatus and we ordered another
kick pedal that should hopefully be
arriving soon my worry is that I hope
it's like I hope it's not the jack
because if it's the jack in the in the
drum set then I don't know what to do
because at that point that's just the
whole drum sets no good I think in the
room I'm currently in in my parents
house there's a bunch of rock band yeah
I see drum track there I'm sure you this
stuff it's like alright yeah I would
love that if because the more important
question I have is what you do with the
drum set when you're not using it well
actually like we now have a we have a
corner that we actually have some space
we've been putting it in which is nice
we would have not been able to do this
in our older apartment I'm like so for
multiple reasons a very thankful we're
in a new apartment at the beginning of
this year but specifically also because
of like we couldn't do rock band at all
no way but yeah it's been it's like
really really funny I forgot out good
that
game is like just what you named your
band
we named I'm not gonna bleep it out cuz
that's too much real guys alright the
best part about it is like in the
loading screens they do these like
they'll have like real images of like
San Francisco or like Paris and the like
superimposed or characters like on top
of them but they'll also put like your
logo so it'll just say like [ __ ] eaters
on like the side of a van or on like a
billboard is our money signs because
that's good that's our it actually
didn't they were like you this will not
work in online play like we're gonna
have to give you a different name and
we're like we don't care we're not going
online with this did you see so a few
weeks ago there was a guy who played
through the fire and flames on Guitar
Hero but he was playing on expert at a
hundred and sixty-five percent speed
right and he got a hundred he got a
hundred percent of all the notes and it
was insane and now the guitar player
from Dragonforce has done it where he's
actually playing the song on a real
guitar at 165 speed so it's a battle
unbelievable that's crazy yeah I know
these people have had years to practice
this but I still can't believe that time
should watch the video because his his
hand is moving just like impossibly
quickly that's nice unbelievable it's so
cool because I want to say with us
originally when the fire flames came out
the original version of that song
actually wasn't even played what was the
end credits one
because yeah so I did this on gonna use
a couple years ago and actually one of
the developers on the 165 percent run
commented and said this song was so hard
we couldn't put it as part of the
tracklist in the actual game that's why
it's the end credits song which is a no
fail state because at the time at no
even I think only one of the developers
could actually finish it was that guy
well cuz I think the original band
didn't even play it live on the guitar
like I think it was like digitally
altered to be at that speed so the idea
that the actual band member can now not
only play that song but play it at an
even crazier speed is like that's insane
I need name again I need proof that the
video is not edited like I need somebody
in the background like doing normal
Suites like they're holding like a
stopwatch or something they can't look
like one of those like tic toc people do
going to see my or something
you see what I you would have enough to
um I haven't really been doing that much
I've been playing a bunch of oh wow
played some Halo Reach or we tried to
the netcode in the Master Chief
collection it is not good and it's
especially not good when two of you are
in San Francisco and one of you is in
London so if you weren't hosting you
would get insane lag and we would have
to alternate perleval unfortunate car D
and our friend in the UK was hosting
they leave the first time and Ty and I
were kind of going this doesn't feel
right it feels weird and he Tam's was
lagging way more than mine was and then
mine start to lag but obviously I get
motion sick so we had to we'll go
through a bit of reach a couple of hours
of reach but then we've been playing
much a tabletop simulator which is
really fun played some greed dice game
we played try to play Trivial Pursuit
that didn't work out so well because
it's very fiddly to do all the cards and
all the pieces and
reason we couldn't take just one card
you'd accidentally take the deck the
whole time
but you know there was lord of the Rings
Trivial Pursuit in there so I didn't
want I didn't want to play that but no
one would play with me
I played Scrabble so it's been there's
actually like quite a nice weekend of
just like playing board games that we
had like a zoom hang out with some
people too and in between I'm just
playing persona 5 which is great and I'm
I did I really really like the new
matter I'm a boss fight I thought that
was really cool
I'm now at the place like 15 hours in
where they've stopped hand-holding and
it's all just the new stuff mixed in
with the old really well or the new
mechanics and cool that was bad grammar
at the end not really been done that
much not been doing that much close
enough it's fine I didn't notice I mean
I've just been I've been playing a
couple things one of which I definitely
can't talk about not until next week ah
another one I guess I can say I've been
playing it but I don't think I'm going
to I'm just gonna save the suspense
every two three if you have it to a flip
preview yesterday play something and
normally I would like to share my
thoughts on that but I can't yet
tweeting an unhappy face and then
everyone else going oh you okay hon
what's up let's try to get some
attention here no but the other thing
I've been playing a lot of his
blood-borne I've been hoping that
Padgett is doing his first run-through
of this game on stream so I've been
trying to play ahead of him so I
remember everything that's happening and
I haven't played that game since 2015 so
I don't remember a vast majority of it
like I remember yharnam and I remember a
bit of the forbidden woods but like
beyond that I don't remember a lot of
this game and it has been a lot of fun
to see those areas again I've been
trying out weapons I've never
used before because you know I beat the
game four times back in 2015 but I only
use the saw cleaver I don't know why but
that's all I did
well now hunter axe is mine well that's
so that's what I started with this time
for the first time and I was enjoying
that but I really wanted to use Ludwig's
holy blade because I always thought that
weapon that's cool
but I never tried it I guess I did use
the crow blades is that what they're
called blades of mercy and originally
because I thought those are cool but
they weren't very effective at least how
I played we said where are you up to I
just beat the one reborn and now I'm
backtracking I did castle cainhurst
which I beat martyr ligarius on my first
try which I remember him doing me some
issues when I originally did it and now
I'm about to fight AB Reedus which I'm
terrified of because of all the bosses
in blood-borne that one took me for and
I am scared to fight it but I did it on
new game like plus plus plus cuz I don't
know it existed yeah so I'm hoping it'll
be easier this time because I'm just
starting fresh I'm not doing new game+
yeah and then on top of that I never
played the DLC so I'm excited to go back
I was gonna say cuz like Ludwig is like
oh my god I think it's Ludwig right it's
the horse yeah yeah he's the one I'm I
it must have been like 50-plus attempts
to beat him I had I summoned the two
NPCs mm-hmm the kid so my boyfriend and
I played through it's really annoying
because we're right at the end of the
dlc and the last and we also you know
finished the rest of the main game bar
the final boss fight i think we've
missed the true ending so yeah just that
one boss fight everything else was fine
like relatively fine we would beat most
bosses three top three goes max ludwig
took hours like hours and i almost raged
quite a few times there was parts where
I was getting snippy this point because
he had Animal Crossing by then so he
just was like I'm just gonna let you do
this and then the one time that I
actually did it he has a recording of me
where I'm looking at the screen and I
don't think that I've done it
and I look serious and I just turn
around to him and I look furious and
then he like gestures to me to look at
the screen and I look back and I can see
you know like tre slaughter and it's
just sheer joy hey [ __ ] meme template
it's like the least cute picture of me
ever cuz I'm not wearing makeup or
anything but he keeps using it as a
reaction omission like I want to I want
to do my own run I've been having a lot
of fun I've also been doing chalice
dungeons which I like kind of dabbled in
when it first came out but I didn't get
super into him and now I'm actually
going through and doing that like the
design they're all like how it works is
like the randomly they're all randomly
generated but the best randomly
generated ones at least I think are used
as like standards that everyone sees
when they do like god I'm describing
this terribly but basically there are
some that are randomly generated and
some that aren't and the ones that
aren't randomly generated are still kind
of randomly generated but everyone gets
those same chalice dungeons across the
board and design-wise like they're
pretty simple but some of the bosses you
fight and those are also much harder
than a lot of the main story bosses like
and a lot of them are repeats like I'm
fighting wrong again in one of the
chalice dungeons and it's so much harder
yeah yeah there's a dog fire dog that's
like unique to the chalice dungeons that
probably the second hardest boss
absolute pain in the ass because it's
like imagine like a giant dog that like
rushes you and is on fire but it's like
the in the arena feels like three times
smaller than it should be for like a
boss like that it is absolutely terrible
it's like thanks
so I've fought that boss once I imagine
I'll fight him again because that kind
of seems like the trend in a lot of
these and I didn't think he was too
tough on that first try I'm I'm sure
it's gonna get harder but one thing I
noticed is his hit boxes were all messed
up like he'd swing at me with his like
jaw and I would dodge back and I
wouldn't be I'd be I don't know like a
foot away from it and I'd still take
damage
that was pretty frustrating because it's
just like oh come on I was doing such a
good job and I clearly dodged it but the
game has decided and I should get hit by
this which is frustrating but yeah are
you trying to get the Platinum are you
trying to go for that I don't know I
just want to play through it for now I
think I might do another playthrough at
some point just with different weapons
because like I said there's so many
weapons that I never used but yeah I
don't know I just want to finish it for
now and we'll see we'll see where it
goes it's been enjoying Greece yeah I've
been enjoying watching that though cuz
he's been doing incredibly well like
frustratingly well like I'll like tell
him to do things like I'll surprise a
boss on him like you bet I can my safe
up here I'm like oh yeah just keep going
there's a lamp and then I walk into a
boss arena and I'll be like alright now
you're gonna die and he'll win and I'm
like come on this is this is no fun you
need to get mad sometimes but yeah I've
been really enjoying that anyway shall
we move on to the topics of the week oh
sure
first one up here is a mafia trilogy has
been announced and it's gonna get a full
reveal May 19th
that teaser trailer look cool yeah it
looks great
like look and the screen shots good
don't think the Microsoft Store was a
post those up were they yes no I don't
think so but is they they also leaked I
assume it's a leak if the full reveals
on May 19th but it was like oh yeah full
games coming in August but it looks
really good I cuz I never played my few
one two I did play three and I got such
a ridiculous glitch in it that I fell
off halfway through oh yeah yeah
glitching that game was I didn't get
through three just because I don't know
that this story was cool but I felt like
story beats happens so far between like
all of this monotony that I had so much
trouble getting through it but the one
that steals the show is mafia one
because it at least based on the images
it sounds like they've done like a whole
graphical overhaul yeah we should be
really interesting because I didn't play
a lot of Mafia one but one thing I
remember is that like you had to obey
traffic laws and stuff in that game
yeah everything very interesting John
Leakey played some of it didn't you you
played mafia one no no I didn't actually
I've wanted to but I've avoided playing
it because I heard how dated it was
games like the the traffic laws things
like some of the missions being real
monotonous there's like this infamous
racecar mission where you have to like
beat like a like a like a Formula One
race that was apparently so bad because
I the story behind this is crazy like
the developers apparently like designed
the level around like a top quality like
racing wheel peripheral that they tested
it on but they didn't test it on like an
actual controller or like mouse and
keyboard so apparently it is completely
unplayable but it's like required to
beat the game and it was so infamous
that they apparently like patched it out
like that you to make it optional it was
just incredible
so stuff like that like I find I think
that game's fascinating but I never
played it I never played to either I
want to meet to is really good I want to
play to because the thing I didn't like
about 3 was what you were saying was
like I really love the story stuff and
then I fell off because it became like
very monotonous checklist II like go
here and take over this part of the city
and do the same 5 missions and then you
go recruit this guy and it was like this
boring like I was like I just want that
story stuff and apparently that's
exactly what mafia 2 is if mafia 2 is
like an open-world but like there it
didn't have open world checklists it
just had you know like story stuff and
so apparently for three they said like
apparently I guess that was a big
complaint for two so then they tried to
correct it for three but then times
change so then everyone wanted it to be
more like two which is unfortunate but
so anyway I'm really curious to play
those games cuz like I I've heard
amazing things about two and I feel like
one I'm curious if it holds up like the
story holds up or how they're gonna
change that game if they're gonna try
and make it more accessible yeah I
definitely recommend playing - and that
comes around because at least at the
time I thought - is fantastic it is kind
of like a classic like mafia gangster
story so if you're not super in the vet
it may be hard to get into but it
it does such a good job of like
capturing the time period from what I
remember and there's so many odd little
details that are in the game like in
between missions you go back to your
apartment and you could like you could
like open up your fridge and drink a
beer you could like grab it you could
call people up on your phone or watch TV
and stuff like that and those were kind
of like being between chapters from what
I remember and like I thought the
attention to detail was super impressive
for that game considering it wasn't like
a big-budget GTA game and then the other
thing I remember too was that it does
have an open world but a lot of the
chapters really restrict you and how you
can explore that like sometimes you
can't just explore wherever you want in
order to keep that narrative very
focused which I liked the one thing I
remember not liking is that like when
you finish the game you couldn't just
roam the city so is like oh I just
finished this game with this incredible
setting with all these beautiful
interiors and cars and stuff but I can't
actually go and explore at least what I
remember maybe they patch that or change
that at some point but I think they kind
of frustrated that lets you do that if I
recall I remember he read that thing up
yeah that'd be pretty cool yeah I don't
know that's that's all I have to say on
mafia knows anything you guys want to
add I don't know anything about mafia
except for the Mafia 3 booth that III
that year was really cool oh yeah I'm
interviewing the developers from hangar
13 that year and someone from 2k so the
very foot in the beginning of Matthew 3
is a bank robbery that's very very
similar to GTA fives and I said that in
passing and someone from 2k was like do
not ask about that I remember that
that's my mafia story what I remember is
the title screen played all along the
watchtower and I was like Kelly that was
cool well I like that song very specific
reason I love that game setting that
game said I would like to go back and
finish it because I didn't finish it
because I kind of got bored of the side
stuff but like I loved that game set up
is
and I'm like that game setting and like
the the had like that documentary-style
like kind of framing and I thought that
I thought that stuff was so cool and so
well done the acting was like phenomenal
yeah really good and but I mean for me
it was just the it was a hot mess of
glitches yeah like well hopefully this
collection is better mm-hmm fingers
crossed
next thing we have here is unreal 5 PS 5
tectum we finally got that PS 5 gameplay
again it doesn't exist yeah I didn't
watch the whole thing but I'm not sure
how much you guys saw I wish a tech demo
it looks beautiful
did you see so obviously they were like
oh this is on PS 5 and Aaron Greenberg
was like or I think Phil Spencer both of
them were like we're using Unreal 5 -
unreal yeah I'm real 5 - because they
using it for hell-blade that's what hell
plates being made in and so kind of felt
very bad for exports after last week's
negate it did Sony just like make a deal
to like have them emphasize that it was
on a ps4 dev kit is that what it was
because in the interview afterwards like
they were saying like oh yeah like you
know unreal - and or the Unreal 5 engine
runs on every platform and it'll look
great on anything and blah blah you know
well that's I mean honestly this is my
least favorite part of new consoles
launching is like the I would you'd kind
of cool it pettiness of like who's gonna
reveal on whose yeah and then you know
the business the business partners but
it's like the tech team I looked
incredible
I think everyone going nuts over the
triangles i I think this is legitimately
really cool like they were kind of
talking about it where they were saying
how like the the statue was like a model
that they took straight out of ZBrush
and just put into the game without
having to like do the usual like you
know work that they have to do to like
compress you know like textures and like
to get that model
actually like playable in the game and
so then they were like oh yeah we can do
that and I was like wow that's crazy
like how is that not taking the
framerate and then they were like and
this room has 500 of those and I was
like how would legitimately why I was
kind of bummed that I know it's like
because the tech is still years out so
they probably don't want to dive too
deep into their like secrets but I
really wished instead of like a like a
just a straight-up interview with Jeff
Keely I wanted like a GDC like TED talk
like explain to me how this works
because it sounds like magic and it's
supposed to like if that stuff is true
which I imagine it is I assume they
wouldn't lie about it like that is gonna
be not only good for like your games are
gonna look good but that is going to
streamline like the production for like
game artists like 10 yeah like that is
gonna be huge for video since I mean Tim
Sweeney was like load screens or thing
in the past that's like the huge big
they still had she still had to crawl
through that little thing about that
tech demo is like the flying at the end
was cool but for the most part it was
like very like expected gameplay like
you're not showing me like cool new
gameplay things you can do with like
hardware it was just more that it looked
really pretty yeah I think the other
really cool thing that I don't know
people didn't really comment until I
think like after the fact when more
people realize that they've done it was
that epic now saying that so for Indies
if or for anyone really it's like if you
use Unreal Engine when you hit three
thousand dollars in a quarter then you
have to pay them five percent to use the
engine right now they've changed that so
you don't have to pay anything to epic
until you've grossed a million dollars
and that's not within a certain time
frame it's like it's until you earn a
million dollars and then you pay the
royalties and they backdated that to
January first from this yeah that's
massive it's really cool yeah cool I
thought was interesting to how they were
talking about how Unreal Engine has been
is being used in movies and they're
creating on
real five in order to like leverage that
as well because they use it in
Mandalorian right but now they're like
okay is this is a thing that this could
become more common like filmmakers might
actually consider using Unreal Engine
for scenes and whatnot like maybe we
should
I don't know create a version of this
that lets filmmakers also go to town
which i think is pretty neat it's
definitely broad thinking I guess yeah
oh sorry yeah
oh noes guess I wonder what L mean for
unity though because there in terms of
competitive pricing the engines right
yeah I imagine unity will still have its
its place its space but yeah you're
right the the whole like not paying
royalties thing is that's pretty huge
anyway next thing we got here is Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 1 & 2 getting a
remaster I had to include this one I'm
excited for this can we talk about the
way the Tony Hawk game via text message
yeah yes I am fully obsessed with Tony
Hawk's social media presence
yeah just public presence I I hope can
people continue to not recognize it
because my favorite tweets what was the
one way he was in Katz deli in New York
and someone was like oh you look just
like that guy I liked look he was on an
airplane and a girl asked him are you
Tony Hawk and he said yes and she said
why he was carrying a skateboard and
someone said who do you think you are
Tony Hawk yes so anyway I really hope
that this Tony Hawk resurgence doesn't
um reduce the number of tweets like that
that we get when I am excited especially
for the I hope the soundtracks are are
still I think it's like me they said a
lava is gonna be the same but I think
some
I imagine there's there's gotta be some
changes to like licensing and stuff but
my gold fingers still on there yes so
they are next I was like waiting for the
trailer like the music to switch to
Goldfinger like partway through just to
like really give you that like oh [ __ ]
yeah at the end feel like I didn't do it
but now they're selling because they did
that live concert of Superman oh they
did yeah yeah they did it live over like
zoom or something that's good one was
like oh that's weird and then it all
kind of makes sense all right
did you see skate 3 was trending that
air skate for was trending that day too
because it was the 10th anniversary of
skate 3 on Monday oh really
yeah a lot of people were just being
like all right well maybe Tony Hawk's
remaster will be so popular that EA will
be like okay it's time now we just gave
for like I was gonna say wasn't there a
thing recently where there was like a
there's a skater who was saying how he
like was in an EA call where they wanted
him to like do a thing for skate but it
was gonna be like a mobile game and he
like told him like no like he think he
said was like nobody wants a [ __ ]
skate mobile game it was like he said I
think they went off online about like EA
execs and following the money and stuff
and it yeah and then Tony Hawk comes out
I was crazy that story from a while ago
about Tony Hawk meeting with an
activation exec and he didn't realize
how successful his games were and they
said they were gonna make another one
will give you a down payment and then
they just gave him like five million
dollars or something there's something
incredible like that is this like really
early like like I think I think so maybe
after the first or second game I need to
look up the story
I remember reading it or hearing it a
while ago and he I just had like lunch
with a game executive just would you go
so I don't know if you guys saw but
Jack Black's YouTube channel Jelinski
got the big elusive exclusive on Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater wanted to remaster and
like they'd probably play the game for
like I don't know 15 percent of the
video and the rest it's just jack black
asking Tony Hawk and all these other
skaters how to skateboard and if he's
doing kick flips right it's pretty good
like I I was like alright I'm not gonna
watch 15 minutes of Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater 1 remastered gameplay and I click
in and it's mostly just Jack Black being
Jack Black it's pretty good how do we
get Jack Black to do things with the
charity stream ski games I would do
anything to meet Jack Black
oh my god my icon
maybe we asked you can you gotta get in
touch with Tim Schafer to put us in
touch with Jack Black and then that's it
only get Tony Hawk on separation we
could do it we absolutely can like oh
yeah we can easily get in touch with Tim
Schafer hmm I think it could be doable
well yeah great planning meeting for you
Jack Black I'm helping plan the charity
stream so I'm just giving myself extra
work I just am really interested to hear
what he has to say about rock music and
skateboarding I want him I want to do it
a cast table read of Miss do and a half
stream of that I found the bassist girl
on to talk yeah cuz it was like oh you
was a you are a child actor or something
and then she does the face
tick-tock is great guys yeah so I would
love to do a table read where it's just
you and me doing the whole movie without
and they're just watching you do it
yeah like featuring me taking a break to
cry about how much I love Stevie Nicks
so anyway Tony Hawk Tony Hawk and Jack
Black you know speaking really quickly
about famous people from our childhood
and their tweets you know one of my
favorite tweets of all time has got to
be Shaquille O'Neal tweeting at Knott's
Berry Farm and my butt's too big to fit
on the seat and the seats on the rides
ah that's me Yellin bat tweet good
people from my childhood tweeting I was
like oh are we gonna talk about Brian
out of MS now first of all someone
replied to his let's face it weird
slightly racially tinged tirade about
coronavirus with more like crying Adams
am i right which was just fantastic but
also grow the [ __ ] up right like people
are dying no one cares about your Royal
Albert Hall residency and I say this
because I've east of bloody love Bryan
Adams and I mean like it's still like
his music but it sucks that he's become
a shitty person you hate to see it
well anyway let's move on to listener
questions if you have any questions you
can email us email us at after dark
podcast at gamespot.com or you can join
our discord server by DM DMing one of us
or emailing that email and we will get
you right in there and you can ask
questions right from there and this week
every question we have is from the
discord anyway Callie do you want to
read the first one sure this is from
chase mm 18 on discord first off love
you guys as far as I'm concerned you
guys in this podcast are the cure to
cope at 19 legally I have to say that we
are not the cure to govern all team that
we appreciate
I was curious as someone who loves
modern games nearly namely sky-god
namely Skyrim I was curious if any of
you guys ever gotten to playing games
with mods if so what are your favor for
giving me something to look forward to
each week you guys are the best friends
I've never met haha thank you
so sweet I've messed around with mods
quite a bit actually uh mostly with
Skyrim but I've done some with oblivion
and recently I've been messin with some
Red Dead mods and I've messed around
some Witcher 3 mods as well I guess it
depends on the game like Skyrim has some
great mods because that like so many
people are familiar with that game the
tool is open and easy well relatively
easy to use some of like the landmass
mods I think are really good I would
definitely definitely do the Bruma mod
if you haven't done it yet for Skyrim
it's like a small contained story which
takes place what south of Skyrim
technically and you go through like you
have to go through like border border
control and you go down to serie dill
and you complete some quests and Bruma
unfortunately the story isn't done yet
they're gonna that's going to be looped
into the full mod that's coming who
knows when but it's really neat
especially if you played oblivion back
in the day you'll definitely really
enjoy that I highly recommend checking
that out video on Skyrim mods I did I've
done a couple actually some like quality
of life ones I really like there's one I
think it's called it I was trying to get
you to I'm just got so many things I
want to talk about here I would I think
it's called a new start which huh always
makes me think of season four probably
one of the few good jokes from season 4
but basically lets you start a new game
in Skyrim in any way you want like you
can say I want to be a homeowner or I
want to be somebody just arrived on the
boat which is pretty nice I'm sure a lot
of these you may be familiar with but
those are my favorites for sky
for for Witcher it's all just quality of
life mods I feel like or camera mods
because there's no actual like photo
mode in that game so I downloaded a
camera mod which lets me you know come
up with my own framing and get Geralt
out of the shot if I want to get like a
landscape shot or something like that
take our photos of Daryl I got plenty of
those I don't need more that's like you
with your teef of photos Lucy I am not
even kidding I said as a joke and I
looked at my camera while my capture
gallery and there are so many pictures
of Tifa I love her I need that games
have pheromones seriously oh god yeah
they gotta add that at some point right
yeah soon because 15 I think they added
it eventually though yeah
just before before we move on I just
want to say Jake does do really cool
videos on modding community even like
large-scale mods I've done one about
Skype live Ian which i think is the best
video I've ever made and then I did one
on beyond Skyrim which covers Bruma and
then I did one on fallout new cat or
fall Cascadian fallout miami mm-hmm so
yeah be sure to check those out I used
to now now that we're done embarrassing
Jake Skyrim mods which is the top 5
scary ones the weak the weak oh yeah but
I personally never played Skyrim on PC
so I would watch SAP and cam put super
cool mods on it every week the only game
that I ever replay with mods now is og
Mass Effect kids I got on Steam and so
if you get the HD texture pack which is
amazing but also there is a mod
specifically just for cutting the wait
times the load times when you're in
elevators isn't there a mod for
controller support too because oh yeah
that's yeah it doesn't support
controllers yeah we do mouse and
keyboard I downloaded that pretty
quickly I was like yeah don't you have a
Mass Effect of the keyboard yeah because
especially the original game is it's it
takes some getting used to I can't even
imagine what
be like a mouse and keyboard it's wait I
well actually I think the originals
better a mouse and keyboard but me it's
just cuz I came actually runs better on
PC yeah than the Xbox version yeah I was
playing on backwards compatibility while
we go and yeah the texture pop-in is
quite severe so I played on PC yeah I
wonder how much work they're gonna do on
the switch versions of Mass Effect one
two and three which are coming I hope I
just wanted them to remaster those
freakin games and I the thing is is like
if they do remaster it I'd want it to be
the ps4 oh yeah on PC stuff because PS 5
yeah I want that game to look hot as as
hot as it possibly can and like yeah I
would love it on the go don't get me
wrong but admittedly right now I'm not
going anywhere
but we've talked about it before but
like if they do it I hope that they make
it all cohesive like you're not
switching games when you finish one
you're just going straight to two
straight to three I imagine that would
be very tough to do especially
considering the jump between one and two
yeah like I feel like they'd have to
rework and rebalance all of Mass Effect
one but I mean to be fair like that game
is so beloved like of all the games that
I feel like actually I should not talk
too much about this because we have a
question about remasters and whatnot and
I do want to say about mods is that I'm
very excited to see what people do with
cyberpunk when that comes out there was
a modding the weird thing is is that
because there's already nudity built
into the game what are all the people
who make nude mods gonna do a fembot
fembot that's what I want to be that was
always the guns for boobs that's what I
want the weirdest mods and um like the
Nexus 4 like Skyrim we're always like
clean faces and like yeah like you can
dig like anime girls and like give give
them like Final Fantasies
lightning hands yeah oh so like the like
black desert online levels
yeah just intensity yes yeah there's
some wild [ __ ] for Skyrim I didn't like
those cuz they just no I hated them
Skyrim it's this like I'm gonna be the
only one who looks like this and all the
other characters gonna look like rugged
like characters like the best mods bro
is the ones that like we're trying to be
very Laura appropriate like there were
people who made like weapons that were
like more appropriate and they would
like actually add them to like the loot
pool so like you'd find them naturally
as opposed to just like you turn in the
game and now you're like cool and I got
this like really powerful sword so like
I I always loved mods like that that
like enhanced the game like I was really
into like Fallout New Vegas mods such as
like made that game like more intense
like me and Michael have talked about
that before about how like we yeah like
mods that like changed the time of day
or like out all these like weather
effect filters and stuff like that I
don't often play games with mods because
I like I'm so used to reviewing games
just as they are and that like I don't
want to confuse myself by playing with
mods and then forgetting what was modest
obviously I wouldn't be able to play
mods for a game that I got in advance
but I'm just so used to like giving
myself the pure experience of a game to
prep for a review that I have a really
hard time installing mods as I feel like
I'm gonna forget what's real and what's
not but I will say one mod that I really
really like is the better pigs mod for
stardew valley everything in that game
is like night you know it's like
Pleasant but the pigs are super ugly and
there's a mod that makes them cuter and
I insist all batshit 8's ap so when I
play on switch now I'm like I can't even
own pigs like what is this yeah it's
weird because I like a game like Skyrim
or Oblivion like that seems fine I got
modding that but a game like Red Dead
Redemption when I was checking out the
mods is like I don't really wanted any
of these mods like I don't I feel like
the game doesn't need this and same with
Witcher
to an extent that's always seemed like
the only mods I got were camera stuff
because I didn't want to like I don't
know I don't want to like change the way
characters look or like change the loot
system or anything like that although
there is a mod for The Witcher 3 that
was created by one of the developers at
C's Projekt RED that rebalances the game
to make it tougher I think which I which
is interesting and one that I've been
planning on trying be I haven't done it
yeah I was gonna say like a game I
whenever I want to go back and play a
game there's that part of me that wants
to experience like I want to like
recapture my nostalgia or like compare
my nostalgia to when I played it so the
idea of like putting on a mod feels
weird sometimes we're like I
specifically want to play that original
version and modding it kind of feels
like I prefer like like like a full
conversion mod or something that adds it
like I think I've got really in like
portal mods because people would just
build like brand-new like levels for
portal and like that's cool because it's
like that original experience is still
the same you're just adding like new
levels for me to play I will say my
favorite mod of all time is somebody who
modded they replaced all of the sound
files in half-life 2 with them making
all the noises I specifically remember
the the gunboat so it's like the guy
being like it's like the boat sound and
then like the water like and then like
the gun be like like all of these are
playing at once and I'm just like this
is the there's a really good video of it
that's aren't you should go check out
it's an amazing art next question we
have here the ps2 Xbox one game keep had
some wild games that have never been
seen again like Billy Hatcher and the
giant egg Sega soccer slam and psyops
that were never seen again which game
from this era would you like to see
remade or given a sequel this is from
Jacob McCourt on discord anyone play
blinks the time cat-back got a sequel
though there's the second one
no inflate it they still make I said
clone OA klonoa oh I believe they do
that was a game that I like had on the
ps2 I think they like a wee one yeah but
I never like followed it and like you
know how little I follow it cuz I don't
know how to pronounce it
I'm just like I can imagine it written
down but that's maybe the only one from
that time Oh Dramat
no that was on a ps2 demo disc and I
remember just playing the [ __ ] out of it
I think it got released and that doesn't
think anyone else ever did anything with
it but it was basically like a
skateboarding game but you're in a
hovercraft
like a hoverboard oh I think I played
that is that the one with the I Troy no
okay that's a mouse super early ps2 and
you would just go around and smash
through billboards and do tricks and
stuff I'm gonna look this up because I
feel I think what's called a blade did
they really concise the blade let's hope
we can bring it back you get that
product placement yeah see results about
video game but it's mostly just the
dyson airblade
I I feel like they've remade Simpsons
hidden run
but I might have imagined that it's
nothing one no I think that whenever one
keeps me wanting people to remake
there's one seems to be my favorite I
love hidden rooms fantastic it must be
hit run because I've every time they
like say something about like Simpsons
of video games everyone's always like
they got to do a remake of like hit and
run and then it always turns out to be
like a mobile update to like that one
mobile game or whatever yeah so there
was a road rage and there was hit and
run mmm-hmm not liking road rage a lot
by hit and run I thought was great uh a
blade was made by criterion oh really
so you also made burnout Need for Speed
speaking of dead franchises bring adkar
now you know what I played a lot of
the ps2 was at home ddr with the ddr
matt i am i got lazy and i would play it
with control how do you like the doubles
with a controller oh yeah i had i toy
was great i mean my friends spent a lot
of time on i toy but i feel like they
did that for PS was there an i type of
ps3 and then i just vanished and they're
like it's sort of it but not as they had
a camera i don't know if they had an i
toy specific thing yeah that was a big
deal for me and my friends comedy for
that fusion frame well i guess there was
a fusion frenzy to or was one there was
a second one I remember it not being
very good and just going back to playing
fusion frenzy one I feel like this is
cheating or like it doesn't count
because it's Star Wars related but I've
always wanted a sequel to Republic
Commando it's like one of those games
there are so many good Star Wars games
from the bat era of consoles oh yeah god
oh gee Bell front 1 & 2 Oh coach oh they
added online multiplayer support to OG
battlefront on Steam really yeah yeah
that's part of Star Wars day which is
cool I went on and it was only like 10
people playing but I was like yeah like
let's go I think I stopped playing -
good final question here Lucy do you
wanna take this one yeah
us it's from foggy bear my roommates are
just gonna take the dog out foggy bear
in discord what are some video game
mechanics / trends that you are
personally over and or not interested in
me personally I'm tired of games being
open-world prime example Gears of War 5
had a really strong beginning that was
linear like the older games then in the
middle it went open-world and the game
fell apart in my opinion we didn't do
this last week did we
no I think I put it on but I think we
skip I don't think we got to it okay
yeah good good I would say like
detective modes
I think I'm a bit over detective mode
sad man lady likes ya inning - yeah like
cuz if you think about it it was I think
it's used well in Batman it makes sense
but you know seeing it in assassin's
creed to an extent it's in Last of Us
it's in you've got Witcher senses days
gone days gone every game has it now and
sometimes I think it's just so that it's
a fail-safe so play it doesn't get lost
which I get it's it's useful but I think
now sometimes it can become a crutch for
missions that just immediately don't
really interest me that much I think I
think like the best evidence active mode
is in arkham origins where you are
basically reconstructing crime scenes
and they did a really cool job with that
right yeah it's like a specific mechanic
as opposed to just like hitting the
button and you're spending like 90
percent of the game with skeletons
versions of people that you're doing
yeah I would also be curious to see like
because I feel like detective modes in a
lot of games and everything a lot of The
Witcher 3 right here is where it just
like highlights all the points of
interest and you just go and click on
them I think I'd be more interested if
they just made that stuff more obvious
you found them on your own right like
that's something that I guess I think of
LA noire right because that was you just
in an area and you're picking things up
and examining that and I find that more
interesting I get why those detective
modes are there though because a lot of
people hate that they just want to like
find this stuff and move on to the next
thing
yeah but then it's just kind of like if
people hate it then yeah I'd be okay
with not seeing those yeah there are a
lot of games I feel like around that era
that we're doing like I'm not into games
such as have skill trees for like no
reason oh yeah
one I remember really bad was Mirror's
Edge catalyst it felt like it just had a
skill tree for the sake of being skill
tree like you needed to like unlock the
ability to like roll and you're like why
like this doesn't even make sense in the
context of like the story like why like
she's supposed to be a season runner
like it felt like it was just like
adding
it's like skill unlocks for the sake of
doing and it wasn't really an easy way
to hide progression or like shoulders
yeah and I always found that really
obnoxious same with like adding stealth
into games that don't need stealth like
like it's just stealth flight like I I
always find it weird when like I rather
a game like really like heavily commit
to like being good at stealth or being
good at action or being good at both but
like it felt like there were and there
are games that were like we're gonna try
and be stealthy but like it didn't
really work like the first evil within I
remember that game stealth being I was
literally just about say I remember that
being particularly bad and evil within -
yeah choose better mechanics to zap me
Bennet but the stealth mechanics don't
work yeah I remember I remember this
annoying the crap out of me if there was
an enemy who was lying in the grass
because there was a ton of them who
would lie in the grass and they would
pretend to be dead but if you triggered
a specific point then they would come
back to life but there were ways that
you could come up behind them you
couldn't stealth kill them until they
triggered and I remember trying that
just immediately pissing me off and I
was like I had other issues of that game
yeah but I remember that one I like that
game a lot actually
as somebody who didn't like the first
but yeah that yeah yeah I agree I
remember evil even the evil within one I
remember that also had like a skill tree
and like oh like a crafting system
that's just like I don't need this I
don't need all this like in a game like
just because like I don't know it yeah
it a lot of systems that don't feel like
they need to be in there yeah I mean
tech is at what point I get it but it
wasn't really open world cuz it was
still like you have to just go here and
there's like kind of mini missions right
I think a big problem I think Assassin's
Creed's origins and Odyssey had the
open-world issue of it being too big and
it was just like content that was there
it didn't feel meaningful competitor I
mean Witcher being the other side of
that coin where it's every side question
which I felt
interesting and like feeding into
something there's a joy there's a toss a
coin tear I know when which drink coin
is in the same sentence that's
immediately where my brain goes I mean
the big one for me John Luke can I
already said I was gonna say skill trees
like that was one of my problems with
Odyssey I feel like this is just like a
lot of unnecessary skill cheese mathavan
games make you walk through certain
sections like you're just in an area and
now it's like all right now you need to
walk - I appreciate Marcus Fenix putting
is his ear - yeah yeah actually when you
have to accompany an NPC and you're
running and they don't run either at the
same speed or fast enough on a Fantasy 7
remake had that don't think I didn't
notice squaring it yeah that's always
thing I'm staying fine that is that is
especially bad on when you're playing on
mouse and keyboard cuz on controller you
can like okay I'll just have to like
lightly feather the the stick yeah it
kind of sucks mouse and keyboard like
you can't do that so you're just like
tap stop tap yeah stop tap I'd say for
me
photorealism I don't think in most cases
photorealism like I think there's like a
tweet I think about like how we kind of
hit the ceiling for like what increased
photo realism adds to the experience of
playing a game versus what it costs to
do that and there's like I really value
unique art style
we're like distinctive art style over
photo realism and I think I'm just kind
of tired I would also like oh no no
continuous I say oh I just I've never
been super like invested in the the
graphical fidelity of something anyway
so that's probably just me I was just
gonna add to that that like on top of
that I find that sometimes that
graphical fidelity comes up the cost of
other things that could have made the
game better so like an example that is
is Halo 5
like was pushing for 60 frames a second
and like really high like quality
graphics and because of that there is a
noticeable dip in like the a I like the
AI in that game is not as complex and
then like there's some like kind of like
GDC talks where they talked about like
kind of the trade-offs of that and and
basically it's like that game's combat
ended up suffering because they were
trying to push like a certain
presentation fidelity and because of
that the the actual like combat of that
game ended up suffering because of it
yeah whatever happened to like
developers really pushing AI I feel like
we don't get that a whole lot like
really smart enemies which is kind of a
bummer because I remember that used to
be such a especially I'm like the Tom
Clancy games that was always such an
important like point on the box like
these AI will feel real and now like I
was playing break point about a month or
two ago and it's just kind of like it's
just a shooting gallery you know you
just show up find a high place and just
pop them all I feel like AI is one of
those situations where like like with
video editing you notice it more when
it's bad than when it's good like like
we've hit a point where like good a AI
isn't impressive anymore because we just
expect the AI to have a certain amount
of intelligence and so like it's either
like so impressive I can't believe the
AI can do that or like this AI really
sucks is just standing there or
glitching or whatever but you don't
really notice like we'll be in between
of that yeah I still feel like though AI
was better in some of these older games
than it is now like I feel like a lot of
developers have just been making games
to make it like I don't say a lot of
developers but I feel like game design
is kind of for a while there was
trending in that position where it's
like we want to we want to make you feel
like a beast so we don't want these
enemies to be too smart when all them
dad's smart you because you need to be
the killing machine here I also think
game design has its trends right so like
mmm different buzzwords different like
marketing terms even that you would hear
as the focus of the development so like
I used to be that and now we're in like
the ray-tracing era are like the like
super nitty gritty technical perfections
that you can achieve with modern
technology versus like look at how real
it looks 10 years ago you look at that
you're like we keep evolving with that
yeah I just never I mean I grew up
primarily playing either like Nintendo
or like doom so neither of those is
particularly realistic looking so yeah
it's just something that I haven't
really guy rim Skyrim is just like its
from the era it's from the end of the
era where everything looks like mud and
like people's mouths don't move
correctly and it is still one of the
most popular games of our memory and you
know you can achieve a lot without
having to put so much because it is a
very cost inefficient thing to do to
make a game super photorealistic
also I'm tired I hate American cutesy
aesthetic I hate the way the fortnight
[ __ ] look it's not cute I hate
that like I hate that folks are [ __ ]
yeah that like dream the DreamWorks mark
yes that's horrible fake fake DreamWorks
I love doing it animation I don't think
everything needs to look cutesy or like
anime I just think like finding more
distinctive art style like disco Elysium
has a very distinctive beautiful art
style that isn't anime or fake
DreamWorks right um so that's another
thing I hate and I'm getting pretty
tired of battle royale and Hiro shooters
yeah I would agree so of what to change
maybe the connection like drop to what I
said that it looked like you all could
the column
by far Cali I offended everybody well
anyways it I think that's as good as
place as any to in this show thank you
all so much for tuning in each and every
week if you want to join our discord
make sure the DM us and we'll get you in
there as soon as we can and make sure to
stay tuned throughout June because our
play for all event will start and we're
gonna have a ton of cool stuff Jack
better what's that
nothing oh I so Jack Black will
definitely be there anyway Lucy where
can people find you I am on Twitter and
Instagram Lucy James Gibbs and Kelly I'm
on Twitter and also on Instagram but I
barely post there at Ankita gqo i NK why
do ji k ko ang Luke you can find me at
John Lee's epi on Twitter mean been put
out a new potato mode where we played
Mortal Kombat 11 and then it's a good
time let's go watch that and you can
find me at Jacob tech and I have a
couple videos that should be ready for
next week anyway
I'll see y'all next week
[Music]
you
[Music]